[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en fait c'est un pain que j'avais
démarré à faire il ya 17 18 ans le pain
s'appelait au démarrage un dreyer
personne n'arrivait à dire ce nom là
donc du coup un jour j'ai dit on va
l'appeler l'euro cote pourquoi leurs
coûts un hommage un acteur italien
adacore à nu à ok rocco siffredi propose
de briguer le poste de président de
l'italie oui et j'ai des idées de
slogans pour lui c'est très bien ça que
je crains le pire mais allons-y alors
j'ai ce slogan la fonction a dit aux
actions je suis ici pour une fois je
veux voir les urnes pleines
aita piano qu'elle apprécie j'ai pas ça
se voit mais choisit atik sais pas trop
je pense mais on avait pu t pour avoir
un petit membre bon moi que je regardais
même pas moi bon c'est votre réputation
apparemment c'est pas apparemment mais
en tout cas jusqu'à moi cette ce cliché
ouais ben je voulais après je vous
l'apprends jardy en tout cas je serais
allé ces films là je vais des acteurs
avec des membres à c'est une barre de
fer moi je me regarde je me dis ah oui
c'est choquant même zorro à une grande
hacienda
[Applaudissements]
il paraît parce que stéphane montre
toujours ça enfin bref oui mais que en
coulis wood un mot
il a monté c'est souvent si tout est
content c'est moi j'ai commencé au
café-théâtre au splendid et tous les
soirs avant que je rentre en fait gérard
gérard jugnot et michel blanc me montrer
leur louloute donc
aux bandas bourdin
non c'est pas possible de faire ça
[Musique]
moi je pensais que c'était un peu
dépassé tout ce qui était à là que la
macarena fin tout ça mais je vois que
non à la queue leu leu en fait comment
dire ah
non le divorce de vos amis peuvent vous
amener à divorcer les chercheurs
d'harvard ont analysé pendant 30 ans les
données sur le mariage le divorce les
remariages auprès de 5000 personnes
énorme panel résultat vous avez 75 % de
chance ou de malchance en plus de
divorcer si un de vos amis divorce
remonte même à 147 % de risques de
divorce si vous avez plusieurs copains
qui divorcent en même temps c'est
contagieux quoi ces comptages exactement
j'ose espérer que le deuxième couple
vous a quand même invité à déjeuner ou à
dîner quand même parce que j'ai fait
tout le boulot il se retrouve à toucher
l'argent ça se profile comme ça
c'est à dire que c'est mal à la belle
mère de ma fille et elle est depuis
à j'ai donc gaston lagaffe et avez vous
quelques
fois sur deux il faut le savoir que
malheureusement je pose une question
voulons faire un peu d'humour et je
trouve que c'est quelqu'un qui me dit
non malheureusement il est mort comme ça
saperlipopette
saperlipopette on dit encore sa croyance
à paris mort
[Musique]
jeudi suis pour rien je ne le savais pas
bon alors justement ça sera l'occasion
de fêter ça est de lui remonter un peu
le moral
voilà tout
carton de wendel
pour l'équipe d'aviron baston sérieux il
les sort via les bons à 7 passes en 6 ou
les des animaux tout leur jus notoire
bon compromis alors il s'appelle semelle
volerie et navigue sur cette corde
perché à 1500 mètres pas possible voilà
c'est dangereux cette semaine sur une
corde ou de grimper sur le dos d'un
dinosaure à ça en plus il a l'air de
beaucoup s'amuser vous venez ici alors
bien sûr c'est à ne pas reproduire c'est
un professionnel
dans le pays ils râlent des bises à
israël des frontières et personnes
habitent n'existe pas du tout y aperçoit
les frontières on est d'accord d'accord
là dessus
voilà
et ben je parle comme je ne valais pas
comme ça alors veminardi ok mélenchon et
on en tire ça suffit oui mais c'est tout
ça stupide alors exemple vous pouvez
partir un peu c'est pas vous qui faites
le
il cogite sur les kiwis n'ont pas le
fruit mais l'oiseau emblème officiel de
la nouvelle zélande alors guy
l'animal mais c'est hyper protégé c'est
difficile à trouver c'est l'emblème fils
a du mal à se reproduire je crois parce
que c'est comme les hauts du jour ils
sont en voie de disparition mais au lieu
de je ne sais pas ce que ben c'est
l'occasion pour les grosses quand ils se
posent ils font juillet c'est bon ça les
dés d'abricot
[Musique]
quand on a travaillé on a le droit de
s'arrêter
vous en avez d'autres godard est lisse
comme ça le revoilà
qu'est ce que vous avez dit j'ai dit est
ce que vous en avez ras reçoit vous en
avez d'autres monsieur de la palice
je suis sourde depuis oui de naissance
les quelque chose contre les handicapés
j'ai remarqué
attention il faut que je monte je
progresse je vais pas y arriver sa
glissade
le ouistiti ouais il est coincé dans la
remorque je ne sais pas comment je vais
sortir de maintenant les
années à
mais
là
[Musique]
j'adore ce métier j'adore vous êtes
grossier vulgaire parce que vous n'en
vous détestez tout le monde d'avoir
roulement un gros handicap 1 avoir une
famille qu'on doit regrouper oui c'est
ça alors vous gardez vos remarques vous
devriez réfléchir
la chose que vous avez sous les cheveux
qui vous reste ça s'appelle un cerveau
ça ferrata
goethe organise une surprise écrit pas
trop gros orage avait la place
[Musique]
mais un atout
mais mais pourquoi tu oublies des prix
en dessous de la littérature les wem
c'est pas la littérature c'est
l'orthographe on est là pour votre
compte si pf vous aurez la possibilité
d'avoir accès à des formations courtes
100% gratuite remboursés par l'état
formation elle est agréée par l'état
s'est pris en charge par l'état cette
formation elle est possible gratuitement
cette formation 100% gratuites en la
formation est financée à 100% par l'état
est tellement gratuite y avoir d'autre
choix possible écrit-elle qui nous
regardent mes bras marlène schiappa qui
vous embrasse tous ministère de
l'intérieur maintenant mais moi je les
embrasse porte à